Yeah.
This,
this thing that I was reading or
listening to rather this saw Sam Harris'
podcast. Very fucking interesting. Because
they're, they're talking about the,
what we actually know about the data
and where it's coming from and how these
people are doing this and how they're
setting these things up. Yeah. That guy,
the comic that you and I talked about
again,
that clip of this Russian who is a former
KGB guy who defected to this country
explaining how it works.
One back in the eighties yeah.
Explaining exactly how it
works and what he was saying.
This is 30 something years ago.
35 years is going down exactly the way,
and Putin is occasional he
guy. Oh, Christ. Shit. Yeah.
I mean that's this idea that Trump's
working with them as fucking silly.
Well,
I don't know about that.
I don't think he's working with
them to undermine democracy,
but I definitely think they've got
some business dealings. I mean,
they were offering him to Trump.
That's not illegal.
The penthouse in Trump tower and illegal,
none of that is illegal.
Don't take that for me.
Take that from Alan Dershowitz.
Don't smarter than both of us.
I'm not saying it's illegal,
but I don't think that he was
honest about that. He said,
I don't do any dealings with Russia.
I don't have any business with Russia,
and he definitely did. That's just
not true. Well, we'll see. We'll see.
That's what the targeted,
they're not going to get him or anything.
You don't think so? You think he's
going to just, well, maybe impeachment,
but I'd even on on what k I don't
even know what they'd get them.
High crimes and misdemeanors.
I don't,
I don't know what he's done to talk
about building a tower in Moscow is not
illegal to have business and what he,
what did he lie about specifically? Well,
there's a lot like what we could pull it
up. Let's, let's find out all the things.
What do you get a lot of?
salon.com or you can go to a bleed.
Million different websites.
I know. What can we do?
We use to establish at the the
fucking social media tilts lapse.
So yes, social media does.
We're not talking about
pulling up social media page.
What are you pulling up? I don't know.
Actually I'm going to ask. Let me go.
I'm like, I'm not a
Trump scholar. I haven't,
I have at my disposal all the different
times that he'd lied, but it's a lot.
So what do you think's going to happen
to him? You think he'll impeach him?
You mean? No, he'll resign or
what? I don't know. Look, I'm not,
I'm not claiming to be any sort
of an expert in legal proceedings.
I have no idea either. That's why I
quoted Dershowitz. Yeah, I think, well,
doesn't Dershowitz working with Trump now?
Giuliani's Oh that's right.
[inaudible] I always got a
Dershowitz cause he's fucking lip.
Trump average 15 and accuracies ms truce
a day in 2018 almost triple the rate
from a year of hell. Okay. But hold on a
second. What's the season? Myths. Truths.
It's a European paper. But isn't
that a little odd? 15 a day?
Cause I don't know it was making that
claim. I don't know the exact periods.
Dean in accuracies.
You doubt that it's true.
You think that's all lie they did just
made up the fact that he lies a lot? Uh,
ally's about, well, first of all, it's
a definition of a lie. I don't know.
Let's see.
It says Washington Post who they hate.
Those who absolutely say the president
made 1,989 such claims in 2018 by the
last day of 2018 of the Washington
Post 17. That's my point.
But let's wait and see what it
says. I mean, they can't lie.
The total figures risen to 7,600. So you
think they just made up all these lives?
Not all of them, I'm sure. But you could,
you could go back with Hillary and
fucking count. You could go to, uh,
go to Fox knows,
and then put all that,
pull up an article of how many
times Hillary was inaccurate.
Do you know what are, what about
Islam is? Uh, what about is, yeah,
when someone talks about something
and instead of refuting it with facts,
they go, yeah, well, what about Hillary?
What about bill? Bill did a two.
What about this? What about that? You're
going to tell him what about Islam?
And that's what I just committed.
It was what?
Cause you were saying that Hillary lied,
but we both agree. You make my point.
You're going into Washington pouch. That's
just Jamie pulled up the independent.
We could go. We could go anywhere, but
hold on a second. Yeah, I'm with you.
I think Hillary is a liar.
I think she deleted 30,000 emails.
I think it's criminal. I think that
the Clinton Foundation's a, uh,
a fucking fully illegal organization.
I think they've rigged the DNC.
I think they, they, they rigged the
primaries against Bernie. I'm with you.
I'm not a supporter now
I'm not saying you, I,
but when's the last time somebody made
a statement like that and it said this
many inaccuracies when Bill Clinton
was in office. Hillary, I'm sure,
I'm sure there was some inaccuracies,
but first of all,
when Bill Clinton was in office, they
weren't, they count Obama's, I don't know.
But that's a, what about ism?
You know what I'm saying?
We're just talking about Trump.
You were saying that Trump doesn't
lie and they're saying the lies.
I'm not saying he doesn't.
First of all, he said what
does he lie? No. First of all,
you know I like to know the definition
of a lie. If he misstate something,
do you think he does it accidentally?
I'm sure sometimes when
you're talking that Mckay,
so if he's lies 1,900 times a day, we'll
have a blatant. Yeah, that's fucking,
it's Washington Post. It's
horse shit. I don't know. I do.
He said no,
he's a bullshitter for sure.
Joe, would you argue that they haven't
been trying to take him down since he came
down that fucking escalator? How
about the deep state? How about,
how about the fucking dossier? What? Why
isn't anybody know? What does that mean?
The dossier. What dossier? The fake dot.
She had Christopher Steele that they use
to get the the Fi's and explaining to
people what they're, what you're talking
about. They know what I'm talking about.
No, no, no, no, they don't.
They don't cause I don't know.
What do you mean the
dossier defect dash matted.
They said they know what he's talking
about. They had, yes, they had tea.
You have to know this, so you'd
being willfully ignorant. Oh,
I don't know the nick. I
don't know. Hey, I'm, I'm, I'm
explaining. Hold on a second.
I've heard these are terms
I've heard yes and stuff,
but you don't know the full extent he
had the oldest is what I'm talking about.
This is as big a story is anything
Trump has done. What is the story?
The Steele dossier that Hillary used,
they went to, you had to get a, a
application defies a coach and they went,
they used a dancing opposites. You're
Christopher Steele, who's a British guy,
had connections in Russia.
Remember when they said Trump was at a
hotel and watching girls pee and on each
other? Yes. That was all in the Steele
dossier. Christopher Steele is his name.
They use that in their application to
get a Pfizer warrant to spy on Trump
during his campaign. That's fact. That's
not me being a right winger. That is fact.
Okay, so, but the fact that that
like that, you don't know that.
No, I remember that now. Oh, that,
that's what I'm talking about.
Then you're just a story as Trump,
you know,
lying about the number of paper does
inauguration. I want to know the,
I want to know a live
from Trump that's a equal,
equal in power as like when Obama said
that you know a lot about healthcare,
that you could keep your health care and
all that. Give me an example of Trump.
Would that big of a lie? Well listen,
I've told you I'm not, it's a lie.
I'm not saying it's US president slide.
All politicians lie.
So you're just saying they stopped
to count it when Trump took over,
they started keeping, you know, keeping
statistics. Like what? Give me an example.
Like look, we just showed you all
the numbers of the Washington Post.
So if I give you another example, you're
going to say, oh, that's [inaudible].
If you go to salon, little salon.com
all right, welcome. Go to ou.
I don't know what you've gotten more
done than any other administration. Okay,
this is a lie. So true, blah, blah,
blah. See, now if somebody says, well,
let's see what it says. Jamie, go
back to it. What are you doing?
But who's saying that's a
lie? Let's see. Let's see.
Let's see what it says. Jesus Christ.
You're so defensive. It's like,
do you work for the organization
now? I don't, but you're putting,
I'm saying you're using the Washington
Post. This is in the Washington.
What is it? Oh, the NBC. Okay. NBC.
Okay, so look man, I'm just reading what's
in front of me. I know. And I'm just,
you're so emotional
about this is ridiculous.
Four cups of coffee and he shot too,
Huh? Oh, please let me know. I'm right.
I don't know.
You made each one.
We're talking how many you don't know
that the mainstream media hates Trump.
I do.
Why would you put your fucking,
because I want to know whether or not they
are saying what? Stop. Stop doing that.
Jamie. Go back to where
it was. You can't go.
Says Trump later said that he intended
the UN moment to garner a laugh that is
repeated this claim.
Seriously since. Okay,
so he says the admire administration
has accomplished more than almost any
administration in the history
of the country. So this is just,
that's an expense as an example.
You're a bullshitter.
That's hyperbole and people were laughing
when he said that and so he was saying
that he meant to say it as a laugh.
There are hiring measures of success,
but it's not true that his administration
has been more successful than any
other administration in history when
it comes to legislation. Trump aside,
plenty of bills in first two years of
President Barack Obama in his first two
years has significantly more
science, significantly more. Okay.
This is just one thing. I
mean, I'm sure there's many,
many other things that you can keep
going over and over again. I'm with you.
I'm not a bullshitter,
but I'm just saying all of a
sudden they keep score when it,
when try [inaudible] he keeps score
because he lies so much keeping.
Who is keeping score when fucking
Hillary was secretary of state? Well,
it's a Santa trendwatching secretary of
state and I don't know how much she lied
as opposed to how much he learned.
There are a lot bigger.
There's a butter fuck fucking server and
about the Steele dossier that that is
huge. That is getting under
covered like nobody's been that,
that dwarfs Watergate when
they unmask General Flynn that,
that, that dwarfs Watergate. Hmm. That's
an interesting combo. A conversation.
I don't know if that's the truth.
I don't know enough about Watergate but,
and [inaudible] felt that either. Is it
the coffee going on here? Well, yeah.
Why is it in strung out?
Could we queen freedom and emotional.
Not Emotional.
It's just I'm just you,
but you're acting as if I'm against you
and I'm not against me. Even if you were,
they'll be fine, but yet I'm
not, you're not against me,
but I'm just saying to call Trump a
big ally than the fucking every other
politician is an exaggeration.
I told no by the mainstream
media who hates his guts.
I think most politicians are liars.
I think that's a lowly
accustomed to doing that.
But I think the way he lies is unusual.
I think it's the usual. It's just
an unusual, you don't think so?
He, he exaggerates like statements
like that as an exaggeration.
Although he did do a lot in
its first couple of years,
would never get credit for it.
You know,
unless you watched Fox knows
you're not going to, but
would you agree that as you get older you
become more like more conservative now?
I was always a bit of a Dick.
I got a tattoo of Nixon on my house.
I thought it was no,
I would say that was, that's a, what do
they say about if you're young, you know,
you're young and conservative,
you have no soul,
no heart old and liberal brilliance
to mind. Something like that.
Yeah, I would say that's true, but
I could always detect the bullshit.
And I mean,
I mean,
I remember watching CNN in an airport and
I first started comedy and that's like
1988 nine, you know, and getting
excited at some of the shit. Well,
it's interesting because,
uh,
I don't disagree with you on
everything and I love you as a person.
You're a great guy. I liked you
a lot, always happy to see you,
but yet you and I here get a
little heated about this stuff.
But this is politics.
This is how divisive politics are.
If it even a person like me would
never, I would never fucking, Eh,
I would never leave here going,
I don't want to do that show again.
I have known each other.
We've known other for 30 years.
That's not the problem.
What I'm saying is I'm just using it
as an example of how divisive politics
absolutely. When people talk
to, I'm not afraid of it. No.
I mean a lot of people are, right?
Yes. Yeah. I, I'm not afraid of it.
A lot of people are fade of bad vibes
and bad feelings and this is one of the
things, but this is one of the things that
makes people tow the line, right? This,
the fear of this kind of altercation to
fear of this kind of like you don't want
that from inside your party, so
you, you start using they and them,
you start thinking that everyone should
be able to use any bathroom that they
feel like they identify with. You
start, you start going along the line.
It's one of the more interesting things
about politics is that if you tell me
that your Republican,
I can kind of guess your stance on God.
I can kind of guess your stance
on being pro life pro choice,
second amendment rights.
It's like all those things sort of
fall in line and it's very interesting.
It's very interesting how you,
you sort of adopt, not you,
but people sort of adopt a whole
group of things when you decide you're
Republican, you decide you're a
Democrat, right? I don't, but yeah,
I don't think I fall into that.